now we're going to do a basic division
bar model we're gonna first start by
reading through the problem all the way
through so we have an idea of where
we're going with the problem then we're
going to restate the question in the
form of a sentence so again we finalize
what it is that we're looking for we we
make it very clear and then we're going
to go back through read and stop and
draw when we when we cans after that so
just so you know I'm gonna put my bar
model here I'm going to put my
arithmetic on the right-hand side I've
put a demarcation here to give my
students some structure so let's go
ahead and begin a school leader has 24
cups of coffee
she gives each of her four third grade
teachers an equal number of cups of
coffee or coffee cups how many cups does
each teacher receive so we've read it
all the way through now we're going to
restate the question in the form of a
sentence each teacher receives blank
cups and then we're going to go back
through it and read it one more time
against stopping where we can draw
something a school leader has 24 cups of
coffee
so we have the school leader actually
let's call those cups of coffee because
that's what I'm representing with it the
bar here so coffee cups I said that
there were 24 of them so I can denote
the quantity you could put the quantity
on top or on bottom
she gives each of her four third grade
teachers so an equal number so we're
gonna have four separate boxes that are
equally sized and then we're going to so
she gives each of her four third grade
teachers an equal number of cups of
coffee how many cups does each teacher
receive so
we're looking for the number of cups
each teacher is going to receive so this
would be my teacher
okay our bar model is complete so we're
gonna come over here and we're going to
say 24 divided by 4 if you have students
that don't know 24 divided by 4 right
off
they may know 12 and 12 so you can make
this into a number bund and 12 divided
by 4 is equal to 3 again plus 3 which
equals 6
so each teacher receives 6 cups of
coffee
you